[발화자 1]
네. 확실하진 않아요, 왜냐하면 한 번도 가본 적이 없거나 이미 가봤거나 해서요, 하지만 저는
누군가에게 도움을 청하려고 할 거예요, 그렇죠? 저를 도와줄 수 있는 사람이요, 왜냐하면 저는 나이가 많은 사람이니까요. 그래서
[발화자 1]
저희 같은 사람들에게는 젊은 사람들보다 상황이 더 어렵거든요. 그래서 저는 그럴 거예요.
[발화자 2]
도움을 요청하시겠군요. 전화로 누군가에게 연락하거나 도움을 요청할 수 있겠죠.
[발화자 1]
네. 네. 만약 그런 상황이라면, 저는 실제로 도움을 요청할 거예요. 네.
음, "도와주세요"라고 말할 수 있겠죠. "도와주세요, 홍수에서 저 좀 꺼내주세요."라고요.
[발화자 1]
아시다시피, 그건 마치, 그 안이 정체된 것 같아요, 왜냐하면 그건 터널이고, 그 터널은
맨 끝부분에 더 높은 지점들이 있거든요. 그래서 홍수가 바로 그 사이로
[발화자 1]
터널 안으로 들어왔다가 터널 밖으로 나가요.
[발화자 2]
마치 물웅덩이 같네요.
[발화자 1]
네. 실제로 가서 수영할 수 있는 그런 수영장 같은 건 아니었어요. 네. 저는 희망을 가질 거예요. 저는 실제로
도움을 요청할 거예요. 그게 제가 할 일이죠, 아시잖아요, 아니면 혹시 제가 도움을 찾을 수 없다면,
[발화자 1]
저는 달리기 시작해서 주변의 것들을 붙잡으려고 할 거예요, 그래서 제가, 아시다시피, 홍수에
휩쓸리지 않도록 하고 거기서 탈출하려고 할 거예요.
[발화자 2]
만약 홍수가 났다면, 저는 수영을 할 거예요, 왜냐하면 저는 수영을 할 줄 알거든요.
하지만 학생분은 수영할 줄 아시나요?
[발화자 1]
조금요. 수영하려고 할 때마다 쥐가 나서요, 그래서
그렇게 하려고 하지 않아요, 왜냐하면 그건 끔찍한 일이 되거든요.
[발화자 2]
꼭 해야 하는 상황이 아니라면 시도하지 않으시겠군요.
[발화자 1]
네. 특히 그 물, 홍수 말이에요, 그 부분은 좀 지저분해요.
도시 일부 지역의 모든 사람들이 그쪽으로 버려지거든요. 그래서 저는,
[발화자 1]
추천할 만하지 않아요.
[발화자 2]
제 생각엔 더 나은 가상 상황은 가족과 함께 좋은 곳에 있는 것일 거예요.
안전하고 그냥 먹을 음식을 구하러 가는 곳에요.
[발화자 2]
그게 완벽한 가상 상황처럼 들리네요.
[발화자 1]
네, 저도 그것보다 더 안전했으면 좋겠어요.
[발화자 2]
여기 질문이 하나 있습니다. 우리는 몇 가지 일반적인 대화 시작 표현들과
가상 질문들을 살펴봤습니다. 이것들을 학생분의 생각과
[발화자 2]
잠재적인 대화, 즉 이야기하고 싶은 것들과 연결해 봅시다.
그래서 우리가 했던 이 대화 시작 표현들과 가상 질문들을 다시 살펴보고,
[발화자 2]
가장 흥미로운 유형의 질문들과 실제 대화에서 다른 질문에 어떻게 답할 수 있을지
생각해 볼 수 있습니다. 어떤 유형의 상황에서 이런 종류의 질문들을 사용하시겠어요?
[발화자 2]
이것을 좀 더 분류해 봅시다. 이전에, 제가 여기 이 다른 질문들의 목록을
보여드렸죠. 첫 번째 질문은 "지금까지 방문했던 곳 중 가장 흥미로운 곳은 어디이며,
[발화자 2]
무엇이 그곳을 특별하게 만들었나요?"입니다. 만약 그 질문에 답하셨다면,
대화 중에 언제 이 질문을 하시겠어요?
[발화자 1]
어떤 종류의 상황에서요?
음, 저는 최근에 만난 사람에게 물어보고 싶어요. 우리가 대화를 시작할 때,
[발화자 1]
마치 어색함을 깨는 것처럼요, 그렇죠? 그리고 그냥 어색함을 깨기 위해, 저는 대화를 시작할 거예요.
음, 만약 그들이 그런 종류의 대화에 관심이 있다는 것을 안다면요.
[발화자 1]
하지만, 아시다시피, 자신에 대해 이야기하는 것은 매우 흔한 일이죠, 누군가에게 소개받거나
자신을 소개할 때요, 그렇죠? 그리고 질문거리나, 아시다시피,
[발화자 1]
말할 수 있는 이야기거리를 찾고 있을 때요.
[발화자 2]
답변할 수 있는 질문이 있다는 것은 좋습니다.
왜냐하면 그러면 무엇을 말할 수 있는지 알 수 있으니까요. 하지만 상대방에게도 도움이 됩니다,
[발화자 2]
만약 당신도 그들에게 이런 질문을 할 수 있다면요. 그것은 대화를 더
원활하게 만듭니다. 양쪽 모두에게 효과가 있죠.
[발화자 1]
네. 특히 제가 답했던 그 질문,
첫 번째 질문이요, 왜냐하면, 아시다시피, 직장에 대해 이야기하기 시작하잖아요,
[발화자 1]
그렇죠? 그리고 만약 그들이 저에게 어디서 일했냐고 물으면, 저는 공항에서 일했다고 말해요.
그래서 그들은 제가 여행을 많이 다녔는지 물어보죠, 왜냐하면 공항 직원이니까요,
[발화자 1]
그런 것들을 물어보기 시작해요. 저는 아주 작은 항공사에서 일했었어요,
그렇죠, 그 항공사는 여기 국내에서만, 국내선만 운항해요. 그래서 저는
[발화자 1]
우리나라 섬들이나, 산 페드로 술라, 여기 북쪽에 있는 곳에 대해 이야기하곤 했어요. 그리고 그건 그냥
어색함을 깨고 대화를 시작하기 위한 것이죠. 저는 보통, 아니면 그들의 가족에 대해 이야기하거나,
[발화자 1]
어디 출신인지, 그리고 그런 종류의 모든 것들에 대해 이야기해요. 그냥 어색함을 깨기 위해서요. 항상 똑같아요.
이런 것들이요.
[발화자 2]
이것은 학생분이 스스로에게 매우 편안하게 느끼는 부분이군요. 이런 대화들을
영어로 많이 해보셨군요. 그래서 만약 우리가 안전지대에서 조금 벗어날 필요가 있다면,
[발화자 2]
아마도 이 질문들 중 다른 하나를 물어볼 수 있을 겁니다. 네. 만약 첫 번째 질문 외에 다른 질문을
선택하신다면, 어떤 질문을 선택하시겠어요? 그리고 언제 이 질문을 하시겠어요?
[발화자 2]
[발화자 1]
네. 다시 한번 읽어볼게요. 극복했던 도전에 대해 말해주세요.
그것으로부터 무엇을 배웠나요? 가까운 미래에 기대하고 있는 것은 무엇인가요?
[발화자 1]
다른 사람들이 놀랄 만한 취미나 활동은 무엇인가요? 네. 그중 하나는
새로운 직업을 구하는 것입니다. 그것이 제 도전 중 하나예요, 왜냐하면 제가 나이가 많은 사람이지만,
[발화자 1]
제 자신을 부양해야 하거든요. 저는 다른 사람에게 부양받는 것에 익숙하지 않아요.
저는 항상 부양자였어요, 그래서 제 스스로 직업을 구해야 해요. 그리고 그건 저에게 힘들고 도전적이었어요,
[발화자 1]
왜냐하면 말씀드렸듯이, 저는 나이가 많은 사람이고, 아시다시피, 제 나라에서는 저 같은 사람이나
제 또래의 다른 사람들을 위한 기회가 그렇게 많지 않거든요, 그런 것들이요.
[발화자 1]
하지만, 아시다시피, 제가 더 잘 준비될수록, 더 빨리 직업을 구할 수 있겠죠, 그렇죠? 하지만 때로는 많이 공부하고
경험이 많아도, 이 나라에서는 그것만으로는 충분하지 않아요, 왜냐하면
[발화자 1]
우리가 지원할 수 있는 종류의 직업에 대해 잘 준비된 젊은 사람들과의 경쟁이 치열하거든요.
[발화자 2]
그렇게 힘들었다니 정말 안타깝네요.
많은 곳에서 연장자들이 동등한 기회를 찾는 것이 어렵다는 것을 알고 있습니다.
[발화자 2]
하지만 몇 번의 수업을 통해 학생분과 몇 번 대화한 후, 저는 학생분이 정말로
훌륭한 의사소통 기술을 가지고 있다는 것을 알 수 있습니다. 인상적인 경험도 가지고 계시고요. 만약 제가 고용주라면,
[발화자 2]
학생분의 이력서와 경험에 정말 관심이 많을 겁니다. 학생분은 제공할 수 있는 훌륭한 것들이 많고,
온두라스에서 기회를 찾는 데 어려움이 있을지 모르지만, 저는 학생분이
[발화자 2]
다른 곳에서 기회를 찾는 데 어떤 종류의 문제도 없을 거라고 생각합니다. 제 생각엔 학생분은
해낼 수 있어요. 그저 자신을 믿기만 하면 됩니다. 정말 훌륭한 기술과 의사소통 기술을 가지고 계세요.
[발화자 2]
생각을 말로 표현하는 능력에 정말 감탄했습니다.